all right hot breath the verse
welcome back to hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
i am comedian joel byers and today's
guest
has been on our list since our beginning
almost five years ago over 200
interviews with comic slater
we now have the one and only gary owen
on the show welcome gary owen to the hot
breath verse everyone
how's it going hey
there's an applause sound effect
happening right now don't worry
oh was it that's my fault no you're good
no we can't hear it on
zoom but the audience watching can right
so uh i gotta i mean i gotta just jump
right in here with you gary because like
i i've started comedy here in atlanta
a little over 10 years ago i've been
known as white boy joel
like i've done the biker bars with bo p
i've done the shady strip clubs with
t-ray
like i never got booed at a gay talent
show
like you have but like i've like i've
always just performed wherever i could
get up
and especially early in my career it was
always just
like the urban rooms and one of my
favorite pieces of
feedback i ever got was from rodney
perry who i know you've worked with a
lot
and um i mean he just told me joel byers
you don't pander
he's like you just you just tell your
story you don't pander to the audience
and that's
that's something i noticed in watching
you is like
there's just an authenticity to your
comedy
that i think is what translates through
to like the audience and people think
you have to kind of
dance in front of a black audience but
what i've learned at least is that
as long as you're real and true then
anything
flies have you what's been your
experience as the the guru
the sensei here like what do you what do
you find the crowds are like
well i think in for novices and guys
especially white comedy starting out
uh back when i started we were going off
def jam and showtime at the apollo
and so if you've never been to a comedy
show with a lot of black people
it gives you the impression it's going
to be rowdy as [__]
you know what i mean right whereas you
know
i think black people just they don't
have any skeletons in the closet
it's just like tell us your life and
we'll let you know if we like it or not
and there's no there's no like i've
i've never seen a black crowd get
offended
hmm that's like the the
it seems like we're in this canceled
culture
you know listen you ain't ever seen uh
urban audience a black audience get mad
because you said a um a certain word
outside of the n-word as a white dude
right that you can't say but as far as
like
talking about a special needs cousin
or an overweight uh you know relative
or a feminine person black audiences
they don't care because they're like
yeah i know that person
that's real life i think more so with
white audiences uh you know
i've never seen it like in my career
or have to apologize for jokes or
something we said
you know a lot of times they're sticking
these cell phones into shows and
we're working a bit out and all of a
sudden it's on the internet you're like
dude i was working something out there
that must be so bizarre for like you
doing comedy over 20 years to see
the evolution of comedy become like
where comedians are almost
afraid to like take a risk now or say
something for fear of blowback
well i i don't think it's like that in
the clubs
um i think live comedy is still it's
fine
people go there to hear the
uncomfortable and but it's when somebody
takes their phone out and puts it on the
internet
but as far as like uh just going to a
live show
it's rare you see somebody get up and
get upset
rare and i've never i've never
i've never seen a black person get up
and leave because they were offended by
a joke
i've seen black people get kicked out
because they were heckling
but i've never seen a black person
if you go on the internet and google
like people walking out of comedy shows
you don't ever see a black couple or a
black person just walking out
yeah they'll heckle but they're not
gonna walk out
you know i had a i had a i did a club in
jacksonville florida and
like the only white couple in there was
the white lady walked out
complaining i was racist against white
people so that just
[Music]
[Laughter]
makes no sense yeah it it it didn't at
all especially like yeah i'm
i'm just like blonde hair blue eyes you
know we're like the
the two white to fail white but yet we
can still translate
but that's her that would be her own
insecurities yeah
yeah i mean it's not you
yeah what is what has been your
experience
with um like white rooms because in
researching you have heard
you know the early stories you're
getting like a band from the comedy
story your first time there and
i know like netflix has said no to you
in comedy central
like is there maybe this is more the
question because
acceptance is something i've had to
really struggle with
and even if it's why didn't that cool
open mic book
me all the way to you know why didn't i
get this opportunity why him not me type
deal
how have you been able to kind of like
are you have you conquered that or is
that something you still struggle with
is that acceptance
i mean i mean i think everybody wants to
the there's still
nothing like having a comedy special
getting released on a network whether
it's netflix
hbo showtime conversational it's still a
good feeling it's a sense of
accomplishment
but we're also in a day and age where
you can put your own stuff out on
youtube
and young comics i mean i you know i
i'm learning this even though i'm in 20
years in i'm starting to treat youtube
like
a tv network it's like your own tv
network
and you have complete control over it uh
i had a it was funny i ran to bill bur
at the airport probably
11 years ago and we sat down and we were
talking about the same thing we're
talking about right now like
uh you know frustration with the
business bill goes you know what i'm
just gonna be so
[__] funny they can't deny
he said cause the only thing he can
really control is how funny you are
because
it's gonna be so funny they can't deny
me
i was like yeah it makes less sense yeah
and that that is something like we're
talking about comedians can
do it themselves now and you
self-produced three specials showtime
picked up your newest one but you were
always like that diy
approach but that hustle of getting
funny first like you driving four hours
for five minutes and sleeping in your
car
and that's like the grind part that i
feel like comedians see
oh i can just do it myself but you have
to get
funny first you know like one one before
the other type deal
well we're in a you know it's a
different grind nowadays like i i had um
i had dizzy banks on my podcast yeah
i've had them on here yeah yeah
yeah we were talking about it and i said
you know the grind's different now now
the grind
is you know get up get your phone out
and let's get with your friends and come
up with a sketch
which is a grind in itself you can just
sit around watch tv
you know what i mean and then to edit it
and put it out there
and you know you're seeing a lot of
these young guys with quality
like programmed it looks like uh it
looks like they had a four-camera shoot
and they're on their phone editing it so
i mean the grind is just a little
different it's still
it's still a grind but it's just it's
it's changing
and we have to change with it you know
back in back in
when i started we were at the mercy of
networks and tv execs we couldn't just
get our material out there
it just wasn't possible there wasn't any
outlets nowadays
you're not you're not at the mercy i
mean look at look at andrew schultz
i said i text him all the time and i go
dude you like
you really inspire me by
what you're doing i said it's a matter
of time for the networks come after him
and they're either gonna have to pay top
dollar to get him because he's he's like
he built his own studio yeah he's got
his own little product though now
i know it's incredible so what it what
are you doing i know you have your
podcast
uh what else are you self-producing or
what are opportunities are you seeing
you're trying to take advantage of and
that comics in general can start to take
advantage of
well i mean right off the bat get as
much stuff out on youtube as you can
and see what sticks to the wall because
you know
youtube is they're paying now they got
you can get monetized you get a thousand
subscribers and
however many views you can start i mean
i'll be honest
that's why i did those lockdown videos
during the the pandemic
i got on every day and just did a four
or five minute rant about
something because one of it
kept me sane kept my brain like working
but two
i'm youtube i was monetized so
it's it's money it's revenue coming in
when we're not on the road
you know mm-hmm are there are there any
other ways we can monetize our comedy
um you could if you get a something
catchy i guess you could do an online
store
mm-hmm there's t-shirts we got masks now
i mean
i talked to duval he he got that t-shirt
out
there um what do you say uh we're in
this together but stay the [__] away
from me
is what his t-shirt said uh
he said making i don't want to put his
mouth there he was right he was making a
decent amount of money off
of just that t-shirt and that wasn't on
a comedy special
he just like put it out there on the
internet and people gravitated to it
you know so there i mean there's there's
ways there's outlets
you seem strategic with your marketing
as well
of um well your podcast get
some you're special hashtag doing what i
do so then people go follow you and see
what's true and what's not
like you seem to be mindful even doing
stuff like the takashi 69 thing
on breakfast club you seem to always be
looking for a way to stay in the
zeitgeist in a sense
is that part of the strategy well yeah
the the takashi was random
because i knew him but i wasn't super
familiar
and then he went on the breakfast club
on
thursday or friday is when he aired
because they they air at the day after
you record
i was coming on the breakfast club
monday i was recorded monday so it was
going to air
tuesday and i literally called my
uh manager i said hey look at this
takashi 6 guy and i on the breast cover
she didn't know who he was
i said he just said he's going to be the
highest
viewed interview they're gonna have i go
and it's happening before our eyes
like he's getting millions and millions
i go can we get a
tattoo artist or a makeup girl
and make me up i said and i'm not gonna
tell anybody i'm just gonna go in as him
it was just timing he went on three four
days before i did
and i just went okay so they found this
makeup girl new york that works in film
and tv
and she really she's gonna phone me we
talked all weekend
i got to new york sunday she came to my
hotel
at five in the morning on monday morning
did all the makeup and then that was
getting picked up at eight
so we got done about 7 45 so there's
about 245 minutes
with all the taps and the hair and then
when i went in nobody knew
like charlemagne envy angela they didn't
know i was coming in like that
so they they started playing along god
bless them
and we just did the interview like him
and then i come back
that was all just oh [__] i'm coming
three days later yeah later so that
wasn't really a strategic plan that was
just like almost for the moment
and we made it happen and then um as far
as the hashtags
um that was a joke in my act right
hashtag doing what i do i said because
we see it came from bow wow
when bowel did and i saw that it said
then everybody got the hashtag bowwow
challenge going and everyone's doing
fake stuff
so then i started doing [__] on the
internet and i and i was saying like
yeah it's doing what i do
it started out as a little joke on the
internet like yeah you know me i'm doing
what i do
and i have bottles or i'd be at some
mansion or something
lion and then that's why i said if you
see the hashtag doing what i do i'm
lying
and i was like i'm just gonna make that
the title of my special
because i hadn't really seen a special
with a hashtag so i was like
i'll just do it like that yeah that's
why i was looking at like yeah the
marketing side of it to where it is like
on one it's a it's a unique title for a
special but on two
it's gonna make them wanna go on social
media and follow you and it keeps you
top of mind more than just watching the
special
now they're following you on social
media looking for what you talked about
type deal
yeah like i just did a post two to two
three days ago
where i said i'm the new host a while
and now i saw that yeah
but hashtag doing what i do and i was
like let me know who saw my special and
who didn't
right cause i can't believe how dumb
people are
what what do you think about the nick
cannon thing you saw him since like
first
like you were with him when he was 17
first open mic ever
like you've seen him since the beginning
what's your opinion on what's happening
now
i don't know i'm really at first i
thought he's fine but
i guess he made a post late last night
of a friend of his committed suicide
and nick said you know as i'm sitting
here contemplating my own like demise
this happens and so now i am a little
concerned about his mental health uh and
where he's at i
really don't know i mean i don't know i
hope he's sorry
it just it just goes to show you man
this this entertainment business
you can have a lot of money a lot of
girls a lot of guys whatever
you're into um but sometimes it's still
your your happiness doesn't come from
that
it's you know we're listening we're
comedians entertainers we're a bunch
for those that aren't i mean we're we're
not always on
we're an odd group yeah you know you
look like robin williams
i mean who thought that guy would commit
suicide richard jenny
who would have thought that guy
committed suicide i'm just like
you just never know what we're going
through never know
what are what are some of the struggles
that you have to overcome
um i don't know like sometimes i
i hate comparing myself to other comics
or i'll see a comic selling more tickets
to me and i'm like ah
wow but i i i've learned to like take a
step back
i don't for one i don't run to social
media if i have an issue with something
or i'm going through something
i go okay is it worth it to really post
this because
i've realized a lot of things are in
your own head well
i'll give you an example um when we were
shooting the first thing like a man
uh you know kev's he's the top dog
stand-ups right
so he invited he invited all the guys
out to come see him at the laugh factory
jerry romney eelie and terrence
but i didn't get invited so we go to set
monday
and everybody's talking about last night
at the laugh factory and i'm going
what and they all got pictures on like
twitter and stuff and i'm like
i did what and then somebody said gary
why did you go
i go i didn't know anything about it and
then
kev literally just goes you ever feel
like an [__] sometimes
but i i think it was just i'm a comedian
and he just assumed i would know about
it or i just hang out at comedy clubs it
wasn't personal
but in the home and i found out i was
like dang
what's wrong with me you know what i
mean here i am a grown man
worried about what some other dude is
talking about and feeling left out
when i really shouldn't have it really
wasn't a big deal it was just one of
those things probably out of sight out
of mind
ah yeah i probably should invite you but
but it was a lot of it was in my brain
too yeah that's i think that's good for
comics to hear though that even someone
at your level
even has to deal with all right stop
comparing myself to someone else
or like well this isn't some conspiracy
to hold me down this was just
circumstance like even someone at your
level
still has to remind themselves of those
realities
and i would tell comics too like don't
rush to social media if you feel like
you have
somebody's having an issue with you you
have an issue with them
i know because i've said it numerous
times in the past
you don't know what's going on behind
closed doors with these studios and
networks and your name
can be getting tossed around and then
you say something about somebody
attached to that film and all of a
sudden
you're not in the running anymore it's
like man
i've seen it happen a few times i'm not
gonna say names but i've seen people
like we were about to hire this person
and we're like don't want to deal with
that dang
but even like you for think like a man
didn't they cut you out of the movie
poster
weren't you like they kind of was that
was that wasn't
they kind of they kind of they kind of
squeegeed you out of a few things is
that
no that was funny it's almost funny it's
funny now
um because my manager was really upset
and i never even saw the poster really
she goes you're not gonna believe it
will packer the producer called me and
said i heard you're upset i go i don't
i don't even seen it
and then he goes oh he said well let me
tell you the
process we were doing we wanted all
couples and then of course kevin we
never really met your wife in the first
one
so i i wasn't tripping yeah i really
it's almost like a joke now every time
somebody posted i'll splice myself in
nobody really remembers the poster
you're in the movie right
yeah but and then honestly uh
my part was probably the smallest of all
the guy characters the core six
because you never got to see my
relationship until the second one
so i i literally i was watching the
movie and i think i
don't know why i tied it one time i
literally disappeared for 38 minutes
of the film you
[Music]
that's hilarious i i've got to ask uh
before we jump into
some of the viewer questions like
getting getting i mean you've worked
with everyone first off
um and that was my favorite i loved you
did a podcast with theo vaughn and he
like asked if you worked with cat
williams and you're like
dude trust i've worked with everybody
you're just like why that that lets me
know
there's a huge divide between mainstream
and black comedy
i watched rogan's podcast also and he
had no idea
that kevin dave chappelle chris rock and
eddie murphy had dinner
like two years ago and they posted on
social media and everybody's like wow
that's an iconic dinner to get everybody
together and for some reason dwyane wade
and gabrielle union
yeah but uh
joe had no clue and sometimes he'll have
like black comics
on his podcast and
or like when i was with theo um it's
like
they really are not in that world you
know
at all and i was like how did they i'll
be watching like how did they not know
that
like when theo asked me have you ever
met cat williams i go
we opened mike i know when he was cat in
the hat with one
tooth and he had the furry kango
and he had the biggie joke he ended his
show with the biggie joke and i'm like
do i know him yeah we're from town
i wanted i would just i would take him
back what yeah what
what is that divide because i mean i've
noticed it too i mean coming up in
primarily the urban side of comedy and
i can i can perform on both sides and
like if a joke works on one side not the
others i kill it like i want to make the
comedy universal but i have noticed i
mean
it's like comedy and church are the two
places that are still like
super segregated like that
i don't i don't i mean i don't know i
gotta i always tell comedians like you
don't choose your audience they choose
you
you don't choose them you just go or
people anyone and i also think a lot of
times
white comics are they're in a little
intimidated by
an all black room so they're like i
don't
i don't i don't even want to do that but
like you said if you're yourself and
you're authentic yep
i saw sebastian manikowska rip
fat tuesday one night rip and it was
just sebastian
mm-hmm and that's right this is probably
i bet you 14 years ago
and when i saw it i go oh that guy's
good
he just went and it there was a time
where fat tuesday was the tuesday night
spot
in um in l.a it was at the comedy store
that's where all the urban exploitation
all the lakers hung out you'd see
you see all the rappers all the athletes
there that was the
spot right all the hoes was there
obviously
so we always beat that out we'll keep it
a hundred yeah yeah yeah
the ball players go i don't know who's
comes first
but of course all the chicken heads
wobbled in there yeah i mean
yeah there's a lot of girls working
really hard not to work
i'll put it out
so uh there was a time though where
they were really starting to like bring
in the iconic
like white axe to do fat tuesday every
now and then like i saw dice clay go up
there
uh then dice was nervous that's the
first time i've seen him nervous
what he went that urban room and he
killed
he went back to the old hickory dickory
jokes and [__] like that
and i was i was watching going oh he's a
little nervous
you know what i mean this isn't his
audience like they announced him and it
was like this
but it wasn't like what he's used to
yeah you know but it
listen he did fine it goes both ways um
judd apatow saw me in nashville
and in front of my fans my audience and
i killed and then he did it he does this
charity thing at the largo
on la cienega all the time any charity
comes up he does these big events but he
brings in like sandler
and just you know david spade he'll
bring him back
or like eddie better will come jam out
it does he's crazy [__] at the largo
but it's all for charity so he he asked
me to go up one night
and it was not my audience it was the
white california and i had to go last
after sandler
and i go what so i got there
and it was i got a picture of myself
norman mcdonald
um what's what's the guy that god damn
it
he's uh i don't know what his ethnicity
is indian or something he just did uh
the movie on netflix with issa rae
kumail camille yeah yeah i'm sorry
i brain farted no your mail was on the
show uh
adam sandler judd hosted a couple
one other guy and i thought i'm first
when i got there
and joe was like now you're gonna close
it out they go what and then adam goes
i'm dude i'm just i'm just [__]
around just gonna do a couple goofy
songs
and [__] dude
it was like watching that the crowd
reaction
was like watching jordan the bulls play
and then right after that
a jb high school team came out right
like they went ballistic when adam got
announced right
and of course they were with them for
his goofy songs and i came out there
and it was it was great because i i got
him
it just took about 10 minutes but then i
brought him like into my world right
but it wasn't like the same reaction as
an urban audience but it still was fine
and everything was cool in the end but i
was just thinking man
if that would have been 15 years ago i
would have freaked out
yeah but now i'm like okay
the first ten just chalk it up to the
game because they're coming off the
sandler high and i gotta
bring them down and then kind of bring
him into my world and stuff
so that's important for like comics to
yeah a lot of times if you're following
someone that kills especially like just
use an example from the urban world if
you follow a comic that does a bunch of
music cues and closes with some big
audience interactive dance and then you
got to go up there
you know you got to remember
you could tell you've been in atlanta
that's an l it's like when i think of
me and like open mic and coming up yeah
i think in my when i've seen chicago has
the strongest
as far as just comedy and jokes
like a lot of guys you haven't heard of
like well that's really good
atlanta i think music bits i think if
you're on the show in atlanta at a
comedy club
who's ever going to before if you've got
two or three guys going for you
somebody's doing some music bits trust
me
but here's what i do i don't come out i
say if you try to close with the music
bit and i've learned this over time
and then try to bring me right up i'll
wait a minute
two minutes i'll just sit in the green
room and they'll walk in here yeah
you're up i got now i'll be up in a
minute
i'm gonna let that audience breathe yeah
you know what i mean
that's yeah that's that's smart yeah
it's letting the audience like you said
following
sandler and then letting the audience
pick up on your pace i think a lot of
younger comics
try to match the pace of the comic
before them
but yeah and acknowledge it acknowledge
the i acknowledge like sandler i go boy
i know you guys are
thought who i i said something like i
bet you felt like jim carrey was next
cause this [__] kept going up and up
i go nope and i said i i
even said i'm really famous of black
people and we only have two mixed people
here tonight and there was like two
mixed girls in the audience i go
fine
[Laughter]
you know but that comes with with time
don't try to just go
like oh this is my best joke i'm gonna
hit it but i think you're right we try
to match the energy
instead of like letting audience take a
breath take a breath
yeah i love it all right yeah and i
think that that kind of ties into our
first
question um oh and uh mit wolfe is from
chicago and he said yay yay
chai town so yeah okay
thanks man word
um oh bobby j said all this goat talk
right now got my head spinning cool
goat yeah goat talk we worked with sheep
back in the disney didn't you
who didn't you work with sheep you had a
summer job where you were working on
sheep or something yeah
yeah the the lamb lambs oh okay
the fam co-op yeah no i think it was
cheap
it was uh i was in an ffa in high school
future farmers of america uh-huh
and i worked strawberry farm my summer
going into my sophomore year high school
so after my freshman sophomore
but i also there's anybody that was in
ffa that didn't live on a farm they had
a
wow
okay sorry about it somebody's calling
they had a sheep co-op
um yeah it was cheap one land you're
right oh
deep nice all right and i was so mad
because
i raised six of those sheep that summer
while i was picking strawberries
so i'm the one that was feeding them
bathed them i sh i sheared them
i sheared them so it wasn't it goes to
sheep because goats don't get cheered
the sheep they uh i sheared the sheep
and then
we go the fair and the other five kids
that didn't have sheep they all just we
like drew numbers out of a hat
dude i picked like my number was the
most malnourished
sheep and when you're showing sheep you
okay
you're the sheep's here and they the the
uh
the judge is doing he does this type of
[__] and you oh you can't ever be on the
side of judge so when he's there he's
always got to get a good look at the
sheet
can't be blocking the sheet and i
remember just thinking god
he's like frowning at my sheep man and
then
one one of the sheep got like fifth
place
in the county fair and i was so pissed
because like i raised that sheep
i go that chick had nothing to do with
that [__] sheep
that was my [__] i wanted that
fifth place ribbon man [__] i love i
love how personal you still take it
you're like man that was it that was my
big break
that was my seat man i was looking there
like this
so in um in bringing in some of the
young comics uh watching here i think
this is a good one to start with here um
this is from amanda oh
asking how did you find and refine your
comedic voice
i mean you kind of every comic's
different
it just has to be organic you just the
more you get on stage the more you find
your voice the more you find your
cadence
your delivery what's working for you uh
it's just it's almost like if you ask a
comic how how did you make it
or quote unquote make it or where was
your big break every comment is going to
give you a different story
it's just stage time is the key to all
this
that's why i say don't go don't take
comedy classes
when people like take them long
five-week comedy classes
i'm like this the only way you get
better is get on stage
that's the only way you know
that's it you can take a class like how
do i
structure a joke or write a joke but in
the end
it's just stage time everybody's
different yeah i think it can help
with like learning techniques and taking
off the learning curve of actually
learning how to write funny stuff
but you've got to take it to the stage
you won't be funny in the mirror you've
got to learn the language on stage
that's it that's the only way to get
better no
um oh well what was there a breakthrough
where you were like oh i think i'm
starting to find my voice was there
something where it started to become a
little more
relevant to you right off the bat i knew
i was the best
i was just kidding facts facts
i mean as soon as i said hello what's up
san diego i knew
it was out well that was not the first
the first time it didn't go that well it
could have
if the comments would shut up um
forever time you know it really was
it was uh so i bombed the fir
first time in san diego at the la jolla
comedy store
and then i you know i couldn't go up
anywhere i was like where are these
where can i go up and some some black
guys i was stationed in the navy with
was telling me about all these urban
spots i could hit up if i want to stand
up
but i do remember i i went up that first
time in la jolla
and it didn't go well and then
the next time i went up was at a karaoke
bar
called el torito in san diego and they
did stand up
on like tuesday or wednesday night i
mean i'm sorry they did karaoke on
tuesday wednesday night
but it was urban urban uh karaoke night
so i convinced the guy that ran it like
i'm a legit stand-up like this is what i
do
and he was like all right well if you
want to come up man i'll give you a slot
we'll just tell people you're not
singing and
i did a lot of the jokes i did in la
jolla
and they worked and i went oh okay i got
something here but i think that was the
moment i was like and i probably did
four minutes tops
but every every joke hit and i was like
oh okay but i remember there's that
moment el torito go okay i got something
here
i got something what what is like your
worst bomb
like worst boo story like what is the
one you'll just never forget
i know i remember hearing one about you
bombing at new faces but like
there's got to be a deep one in there of
like out on the grind of the road or
something
new faces hurt a lot because
uh there was the montreal comedy
festival as far as like
i felt like it was a missed opportunity
was new faces
in montreal um because
i didn't listen to my gut on that one
because i had been doing i've been doing
like the same five minutes for a couple
months
and i was like okay i got the five
minutes that's quote unquote gonna get
me the deal or the tv show
and we get to montreal and i'm the first
comic
on the first new faces show and it's
like 6 p.m
and there's daylight coming in it wasn't
a good stand-up setting
and i looked in the audience and it was
just old and white like i'm not lying
i saw one with blue hair i'm not like
whim over my blue hair i saw one and i
went
oh [__] they're not gonna get my jokes
so i'm literally
i'm pacing backstage i'm like okay i'm
gonna i'm my wife was my girlfriend at
the time
and i said i'm gonna switch my act up
i'm gonna do some [__] for this audience
and she goes
uh okay so she went and told my agent at
the time
and he came backstage and said don't
change your act
and i go huh he goes i got agents out
here i got network execs
he was like they're um they just want to
know your point of view
so don't worry about the audience
reaction they just want to know your
point of view
i was like oh no and then i went out
there i listened to my agent at the time
i didn't get half a chuckle
i didn't get a smile right
and i got off stage and my hotel was
about two miles away
and i went out the back door and i just
started walking
and my uh my my girlfriend or my wife
had
now seen my wife um my agent goes hey
there's some network ex i want to talk
to gary
she goes he already left he's gone
and i walked back to my hotel i remember
sitting there and she walked she caught
up with me and she was walking like
20 feet behind me and she was just i was
just like i don't want to talk i want to
talk
and then i get back to the hotel and it
was a
i had a day off before i could go up
again and i didn't go to any parties i
didn't go to any of the shows because i
thought they was going to say like
that's the guy that bombed
that's the guy i come back two days
later
i found out everybody mom everybody
bombed on that show and
what and i was thinking well they could
have bombed as bad as me
but i go back and that's the first time
i've seen the other seven comics on the
new faces show that was with me there
was eight of us
and they're all complaining about two
nights before they go man that audience
sucked they really sucked and i was like
what but i still
i still don't feel that's an excuse i
feel like i could have got
more out of that set and probably had
more
heat on me coming out of there without
that but
it ended up working i ended up getting a
tv deal with quincy jones
out of that um weekend because what
happened was
i went up the second night
uh new faces and i did a different five
minutes this time i listened to myself
and it was better then guy tori missed
this flight
uh or his flight got canceled he
couldn't make the urban show so they
asked me to do the urban show
which was that was my ball that was that
was home for me right
right i did the urban show
i figured two shows that night so the
first show i did clean the second show i
did dirty
and i did it on purpose and i did two
different sets so
i went to montreal and i did a total of
20 minutes but i did
four five different acts
sets and quincy jones i did not know
this was at every one of my shows just
by chance
and he said to me he goes he i got a
deal out of it because he goes
out of everyone i saw this weekend he
goes you adjust it
he goes and you kind of made a comeback
you figured out oh
what was going on and what i need to do
and because then i you know my second
night
i didn't even worry about a point of
view at the new phases i just did [__] i
saw in montreal
and i you know i got the crowd like
build a rapport with him a little bit
so that i got my deal with quincy dang
from the ashes rises gary owen
and the tv still didn't go anywhere
but it was cool to hang out with quincy
jones for a summer oh i bet it was oh my
gosh
um this could this could be about like
all
all you had all these different sets in
your head uh
a few people are asking about your
writing process and maybe any like
tips or exercises you recommend
i don't really write jokes down on
pieces of paper
um i might like put a word in my phone
in the notes section but i don't i don't
think i've ever written a joke
out like written it out ever oh it's
just
no just i i'll write a word right
but i can't write hey what's up what's
going on
i just i might write a word a bullet
point but but
you know before this corona thing and i
was on stage so much
you know it was everything was always
fresh in my brain it was never like i
took
months off so yeah but i don't
like i said some comics work that way
i've seen like jeannie garofalo brings
her notes on stage
and then it's funny because sometimes
i'll forget something and i'll get
reminded
you know because i was selling i was
selling these t-shirts on the road right
and one lady came to my show a couple
weeks ago and i haven't been on the road
in a while
and she was wearing one of the shirts i
go oh my god i forgot about that joke
i completely forgot about that
do you record your sets and review them
or anything or
just i hate watching myself right i hate
it
stand up like this uh it's just like i
hate going to stand-up shows now
i hate i hate going to comedy clubs
because i i see a mic in a stage i want
to get on it
i don't want to watch somebody else you
do it i feel like they're
just i'm not i'm just nervous energy the
whole time i'm like ah
i want to move around and i can't just
sit there and enjoy it
yeah just goat goat-ish we're talking
right now so everyone asking about his
process
is he's just born with it you know
right that's it just natural
yep um here's one about acting from alex
wren he says i see so many actors
are yeah basically um do you recommend
comedians take acting classes and does
one help the other
like comedy and helping acting and vice
versa
oh yeah i i think you definitely have to
take acting classes in the beginning for
sure
and just to freshen up sometimes um but
like i was talking
i think one hand feeds the other like
i think i was talking to michael ealy
about it and he goes you know comedians
he goes he's kind of envious of us on
set when we're when we're all working on
films because we're kind of fearless
like we'll we'll and live something and
see if it works and if it doesn't we're
like ah [__]
we're like a lot of actors just stick to
the lines because man you comedians
we'll be going over lines and we'll be
thinking god damn it i got to work with
gary tomorrow he's going to say
something that
is not on this script
i never you know i don't try to shock
people on set but i
i run it by them before we go i'll be
like hey i might try something
right here just so you know it's coming
oh that's cool i won't count what
what's it like being in getting to be in
scenes with like someone like kevin hart
what's that like
me and kevin and friends for so long
that wasn't really nothing to me
are you guys other people that would be
like trippy like i'm doing a movie
we were shooting a movie right when the
pandemic in i got to finish it whenever
they let us film again but
i was doing with david kechner who i'm a
big fan of
yeah we got a lot of feet together and
he's a dick to me and i'm
i was like i was really enjoying and
learning from him
i was like oh now i get it like you're
like how did he get that part how did he
get that part
then when i see him and actually i'm
like oh this guy's good he's on top of
his game
he's completely on top of this game
mm-hmm
yeah um and this one this one takes it
back to the beginning with a
kari dodson asking start it off starting
off in comedy how often were you
performing in a week and did you use the
exact set or would you switch a joke or
two around with that set
oh i think in the beginning you're doing
the same five ten minutes
every night it's like verbatim uh i i
remember first time i saw like a
headline and act like a guy went up did
an hour and i was like
what the [__] like in person i was like
in
awe i was like holy [__] this guy's the
greatest comic in the history of
comedians
he just did an hour and it was good
and i i can't tell you who the guy is i
don't know
but i think i think most comics in the
beginning you just got your five or ten
minutes man
and you just getting that perfection
down
and then how do you have any tips for a
comic looking to kind of
maybe they have that five or ten minutes
what's what's the next step
after you get that five to ten minutes
like i said it's just stage time the
stage and don't i see what
we we get so caught up in audience
reaction where we don't realize like
comedians like when we're watching
somebody especially me
i don't give a [__] if the audience is
laughing or not when i'm watching
somebody likes opening for me or
something
i'm looking at is this guy original is
he like bearing his soul on stage
because it's almost like what chappelle
said on his last
netflix thing the 846 he goes i got some
[__] jokes
i was like those are easy you know like
we'll be like
who likes getting a dick sucked i go
everybody does
hey guys straight guys everybody's
giving this up that's an easy one
but when you're up there and you're
doing something i haven't seen or you're
talking about your family and or your
kids or what
whatever and it's original i don't care
all this is laughing or not
i'm like okay i can work with that guy
now if you're doing hacking stuff
but the audit and you're killing i'm i'm
just looking at you like
that you didn't work that wasn't your
stuff you know what i mean
yeah it's true yeah even with the music
i used to do music bits oh really
it's like to me it's like karaoke comedy
you're cheating you know what was your
you're doing a bit
you're doing like one music bit i get it
but when you go into like three
four i'm like and then they get mad at
the dj if the dj messes up
oh i know right you know
they [__] up yeah come on dj and then
the dj's back there just like dude this
is the fourth song
yeah i i i have music bits in the past
but i just went
one i can't you can't do them on tv it
doesn't translate at all
on tv and that's where you're going to
hit the masses
you know but that's just the older i get
i'm like
it is what it is are are you
uncomfortable in front of white
audiences
because like i'll go like i'll like
i feel a little more confident from a
black audience when it's all white
audience i'm like all right let me let
me get my bearings together real quick i
almost feel like i gotta
shift i do the same act but my mint my
mentality is a little different
going into it well i always say like
you've got to play to your audience but
don't pander to them like ronnie said
earlier
like it's almost like like if i'm doing
showtime at the apollo
i'm not gonna talk about tim mcgraw
right
if i'm doing the west virginia state
fair i'm not going to talk about nba
young boy
that you got to know who your audience
is and you play to them you don't pander
but you play to them you got to do like
you got to do some joke like some jokes
i
know would not play well with an
all-white audience
so i just i'll just cut it out they they
won't get it
um you know but but 90 of the [__]
funny's funny
and you're you my wife's still mick i'm
my wife's still black my kids are still
mixed
so that my job is to write it write the
joke so everyone can get it even
like my black church joke like i've done
that
all over the country white audiences i
would i was doing colleges when i wrote
that joke
and a lot of times you go to colleges
it's almost all white kids at some of
these schools
the joke still worked you know what i
mean
still works so um
i think this is a good one we can start
to land this plane here uh we appreciate
your time too gary thanks for doing this
man this is
awesome um this is an interesting one
from mitt wolf
who um he said yay uh shy town
um this is interesting because i think
as comedians we
it's a single-player game in a lot of
ways it's us on stage it's us
most of the time writing the jokes and
things like that but like when it comes
to building a team he's asking from the
advice of
anyone interested in going to talent
management who are the people on your
payroll you couldn't live without but
maybe that could also translate for
comedians who
are looking to build a team to really
scale
their um their career like what what is
that process who do we need first
how do you start to formulate that team
that that has to happen organically um
you know agents will find you managers
will find you
i will say this don't ever sign on a
piece of paper
with a manager or an agent i've never
signed the only
time i ever put my name was the first
manager i had
and it was a nightmare trying to fire
him
and every other agent the manager i've
had
we've never signed nothing they rep me
and if
i don't if i want to leave i leave i you
know
i've been with some of the biggest
agencies out there
none of them have you signed anything
they just rep you
so somebody's like it's one of those
things like
you know they get you in a contract and
then they want a piece of everything you
got
in the future and that's how it works
you know
so i would say just don't sign nothing
just say you're my manager
manage me and if i'm happy and we're
working together i'm not gonna need a
new one
i've had the same manager for 15 years
you know that's what i heard with like
dave becky and kevin hart they always
just had a handshake agreement there was
never any dotted line
that's most good managers i mean
that's just not kevin hey that's most
that's great to know yeah
good you're not you're not you're not
going somewhere else
and we i mean listen me and my man we've
had our moments
disagreements and and everything but
it's never gotten the point where i want
to leave because you know i know
she she cares about my well-being and my
career
you know agents same thing these smaller
agencies want you to sign
i'm like don't sign nothing just say you
rep me
all right i love it give me some work
give me some chances to get work
that's because that's been i've been on
the independent like since day one you
know i've been doing it 10 years i just
like self-release my own
comedy special i've really been doing
everything myself
but it is at a point to like well when
do you need a team
to really start maybe getting momentum
and focusing on your strengths and
letting other people bring their
strengths into it you know what i mean
and find you know fun people like
working with like if you look at like
bring up desi again and king batch and
and
some of these youtubers you know they're
just
they just working with their friends i
bet they all know how to
everybody has a trait like he's talent
he does good in front of the camera this
guy's good at editing
this guy's good at this and then who
knows you bring them all along
eventually and how did you sell your
special like i just
i'm selling mine right now on my website
you just pitched it to different
networks and then eventually like
showtime
well i um let me tell you something i
did two that didn't get bought
oh okay my first two did not get bought
by anybody
i got one called uh breaking out the
park and one called urban legend
that i was selling as dvds on the road
and nobody bought them and i think
i think breaking out the park is one of
my best specials
out there just i didn't have a big
enough name i didn't have the right
representation
but networks and they didn't really know
who i was at the time even though i
host a comic view they didn't really
know but
um now it's crazy i've
ended up selling both of them 10 years
and 15 years after i recorded them i
ended up selling
it to like different studios that gets
it out on itunes and
everywhere else so i ended you know it
took me years but i sold it but
the first two mine didn't sell but it
didn't discourage me
i was like all right one i got sick of
doing the material
and i wanted to do new materials i was
like let me put a special together
and we just we shot it hired the camera
guys paid everybody i owned all the
rights to it
and then that's all i did because i
wasn't getting
nobody was like calling me to shoot to
uh
we want to do your special and pay you
for it so i was like well i'll just
shoot it myself
and hopefully i'll sell it and luckily
um the true story i didn't do by myself
co black did it but that sold the show
time
so that helped my relationship with show
time it did good on there
so the next one i just did myself and
everybody passed but show time
it shows i was like oh okay we remember
your last one even though i didn't do
that one
that's how i've sold my last three to
showtime they were like i did it myself
but they're like oh okay
he does good numbers and you know
you know just it works out yeah there's
several people in the chat saying
they're going to buy it
right now they're going to buy both
right now they said so
breaking out the park is probably
i think we shot that in 2001 mm-hmm
i look like a little kid in there
because this is why i remember when we
shot it because
literally the we shot at draft weekend
and
san diego was supposed to pick michael
vick it's weird how you remember things
and they traded the pick in atlanta pick
michael vick and san diego got ladainian
tomlinson
and for some reason i was in san diego
that weekend shooting that special
and i just remember that was the big
news in the area like damn we supposed
to get michael vick
that's what i remember about my friend
that's how long was well this
yeah this was definitely a moment in
this show in my career i won't forget so
i i appreciate you taking the time to do
this gary
i i realized we ran a few minutes over
but thanks for
seriously doing this um we're always in
this
with like just closing advice for comics
something you've picked up through your
career advice you'll never forget
something you can kind of end us with
here
you're never as funny as your best set
and you're never as bad as your worst
[__]
i'll leave it at that don't get too
depressed but also don't get too cocky
awesome and how much did that special
cost break out breaking out of the park
self-produced do you remember um
here's the thing i got i had my tv deal
with quincy jones
and i took that money and shot my
special i think that special end up
running me about
55 000 okay and i made
i'm i remember i made like 23 000 back
at the door that night because i had
bought the theater too
so i was like with 30 i was like 30 some
thousand dollars in the hole
after it was all said and done and then
i went shopping it
and nobody bought it and that was a
little disappointing
but then i boxed it started selling on
the road for twenty dollars
so it might have taken me two years but
i made the money back so
awesome and then i end up getting
you know i end up buying it somebody end
up buying it
for more money than what i paid to make
it granted
15 years later 16 years later but it
ended up
working out because i had it and i owned
it the come up
as they say kids people are saying
thanks gary and joel
this was great a lot of people very
complimentary um is there anything you
want to promote that we can put into the
description of this show for people to
go check out
um i got a netflix movie coming out
september 29th
with michael j white called welcome to
sudden death it's a remake of the john
claude van damme one
okay i haven't seen it know
that's like my first league like it's me
a mike that's awesome it's like a rush
hour
so we're like it went from an action
movie to a buddy comedy because i just
started
wilding out on some of the scenes yeah
let's make it exciting
shot at about to get murdered
so that's that's probably that's
probably next and you know
my special you know i got specials
everywhere i got them
on hulu i got them on amazon prime i got
them everywhere but netflix
not that you're bitter or anything not
that you're bitter anything
no it is what it is there's nowhere to
get better as long as you get them out
there
facts facts and go listen to his podcast
as well get some that's a good one as
well
yeah yeah we got who we got coming up
this week we've got um
romney malco the last thing like a man
cast member
oh my gosh yeah i got russell peters
i'm recording him this week and lunell
those are the three i got
because we record them in advance
sometimes right of course yeah yeah
i'm recording three this week so those
are the three those will be the next
three weeks yeah i had lanell
on a week or two ago and um
kev hadn't gotten back to us yet we're
gonna get kev real soon though
um you know kevin hart we're sorry we're
on kev
name basis i don't i still call him hey
let me tell you when i started my
podcast i was worried i was like damn i
don't
i don't if people say no i don't it's
going to let me know how people feel
about me right
right everybody said yes i was like
thank god that's awesome
everybody because you know they're not
getting none out of it when tiffany does
it
when kev does it um you know they're
they're not getting anything out of it
they're basically doing it for my sake
you know yeah that's why i'm so grateful
you did this because i mean you didn't
have to do this
you know it's your afternoon just
hanging out yeah you definitely didn't
have to do this so i appreciate it
i was late i was i blamed the sauna man
i'm like damn i know i'm supposed to
deal with something today no i'm glad
you you were getting fret you're getting
your mind right
for this you know you're getting the
toxins cleared out so you could be
hot on hot breath here well you know you
you try to come up with a lie
and i've done realizing this business
just tell the truth dude i
i i messed you up i brain farted [__]
i'm sorry
i'm just glad you got back because i was
in the group like guys he may have
forgot
i don't know what happened as they're
like crying i mean it's all good though
i knew i was like we're gonna cross
paths gary so we're not gonna get curved
now
yeah but yeah thank you so much for your
time gary enjoy your show tonight and um
i'll let you know when this is out okay
man appreciate man thanks gary
you